good evening I am Spartacus
welcome to the Washington C campus of
Hillsdale College this is the Alan P
Kirby Center for Constitutional studies
and statesmanship and I'm actually
Matthew Spalding who among other things
is the I'm the Dean of the new Graduate
School of Government we are starting
here in Washington DC for those of you
that are interested our newest and that
our latest innovation we have a very
interesting conversation tonight with
what I think is actually a fabulous book
the first book on the Cavanaugh hearings
and his process of confirmation to the
United States Supreme Court now if
you're like me you watch that very
closely it was messy it was political it
was high drama and I was glued to it
every moment of the way such our deals
have happened in the past past
confirmation hearings we recall Robert
Bork Clarence Thomas but there was
something very different about this one
it was very interesting there were
twists and turns all along the way I'm
also used to reading political books in
Washington DC I love politics and most
political books aren't very good they're
mostly written by politicians getting
rare for campaigns this is not one of
those books it's written by a JD from
Harvard who testifies to Congress and
writes briefs as for the Supreme Court
and one of the top journalists my
opinion in our times and as a result is
a wonderful book compelling narrative
and a great story and I have to give
them a lot of credit for that so thank
you for joining us thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
molly-molly Hemingway is a senior
journalism fellow at Hillsdale College
here in Washington DC
she's also senior editor of The
Federalist and a fox news contributor
she received her BA from the University
of Colorado at Denver she has been a
Phillips foundation trellis and fellow a
lincoln fellow at the Claremont
Institute for the Study of statesmanship
in political philosophy and Napoleon
distinguished Visiting Fellow in
journalism at Hillsdale College our main
campus the mothership in Hillsdale she's
written for numerous publications
including the Wall Street Journal the
Washington Post Christian today and
she's also the author of Trump versus
the media before justice on trial Kerry
Severino is chief counsel and policy
director of the judicial crisis network
she received a BA from Duke University
in MA from Michigan State University and
a JD from Harvard University she's a
regular guest on numerous television
outlets including MSNBC Fox News CNN
c-span and ABC she has written and
spoken on a wide range of judicial
issues including the Costas limits on
government federal nomination
confirmation process and state judicial
selection she has testified before
Congress on constitutions and brief
senators on confirmations and does
actually write regularly briefs in the
United States Supreme Court
my objective tonight is to talk to them
for about half the time 30 minutes or so
and then open it up to questions
and try to draw out some things in this
book because there are in reading it I'm
reminded of so many things going on and
so many moving parts and inflection
points throughout I want to try to
summon draw some of those out but let me
begin by asking a general question which
is why do you write this book it was
written very fast well done but you had
a purpose here and what was that and why
did you do it and why do you spend that
much trouble to get it out right and
before I get to that you noted that this
was written quickly obviously it was
nine months ago that we finished this
hearing and it is a very thorough it
took a lot of time and research we
interview
more than 100 people from the president
and other high-ranking people at the
White House throughout the Department of
Justice members of the Supreme Court
many senators and it took a lot of time
we had took a lot of reading of
historical records and whatnot and we
could not have done it without actually
the Kirby Center here we had research
assistants in journalism assistants that
were provided to us that were of of
great value and we are so appreciative
of them and in particular I would like
to just point out Alex Nestor who helped
us with some of our reporting and
Solomon Chen and Christina Kirk who is
Kirk who did so much so much research
and help and we are we are so grateful
and just having those resources provided
to us we are very appreciative of that
support this could not have been done
without that level of support and we
appreciate it thank you
[Applause]
so we wrote this book because we knew
this was really one of the most
important things that happened last year
it wasn't just Brett Kavanaugh who was
on trial it was really justice itself on
trial in the in the attacks that we saw
in due process in the attacks on the
presumption of innocence and we wanted
to make sure that that was more
thoroughly explored i clerked for
Justice Clarence Thomas in the Supreme
Court and so of course a lot of the the
attacks and the smears on Cavanaugh
looked familiar to anyone and I'm sure
many people in this room saw those
hearings and reminded of a need a hill
when they came to this but I was
concerned about the next phase and that
is after Thomas was confirmed they
didn't stop the attacks then the day he
was confirmed two to one Americans
thought that Hill was more was it was
less credible than Thomas they believed
him and yet in the ensuing decades we've
had a drumbeat of misinformation and
disinformation about what went on there
and it's really tried to change the
narrative we wanted to make sure that
wasn't possible with justice Cavanaugh
we thought the best way to do that would
be to get the facts out there and so
that it may the American people can just
read them you can you can make your own
congressional what happened and so we
tried to pack as much in there as
possible so weight pack a lot in theirs
is one way of putting it there are so
many different facets to this and just
reading through it you're reminded while
all these little twists and turns along
the way that seem like you know decades
ago but it was all compacted in such a
tight timeline and and it's let's view
that a little bit first and then I want
to I want to ask you about what do you
think were the key turning points and
what what looking back you after that a
little bit of hind you a bereavement I'm
hindsight what were those inflection
points and what do we learn from and
start drawing that out but first let's
do sit and remind us a little bit of the
overview your book lis kind of goes
through that that narrative you refer to
which is actually kind of complicated
right we thought we knew a lot about
this because we'd both been you know
covering it and involved in the process
and then after we interviewed all these
people we realized we didn't know half
of it and we lay it out in a very
chronological fashions
we begin we begin prior to the Cavanaugh
Cavanaugh being nominated we talked
about about the 2016 election which was
very important for this issue because
Donald Trump is running for president
and doesn't have the confidence of
conservative voters particularly on the
issue of judges and then it's already
bad for him but then Justice Scalia
passes away and it's a very important
issue that's at the forefront of all
conservative voters Minds so he that
night happens to be a debate and he does
something that hadn't been done prior
where he actually names two current
judges who he thinks would be good
nominees to the Supreme Court and
usually people would say oh I'm thinking
about nominating someone in the mold of
Thomas but they would not get that
specific it goes over really well with
his voters and he gets this idea to come
up with a list a list of prospective
nominees so we go through this looking
at how that list was developed the fact
that people were being vetted in a
primary you know before the or the
nomination is even secured she was just
an amazing level of effort went into
having good nominees he releases the
list he updates the list it ends up
being so important that one in four of
his voters say that's why they voted for
him was the Supreme Court so looking at
that issue and also ylist was important
because Republican voters had lost
confidence in Republican presidents to
do a good job with companies there had
been people electing Republican
presidents who promised to put good
people on the court and then there when
their nominee came it would be a
disappointment so the list was important
for really showing no and saying I will
only do pick from this list was very
important so that was an important point
going through the primary battle for who
would eventually get this this
nomination for the for the seat that
Cavanaugh now fills but putting that
list together was important because of
what they were looking for they were
looking for people who had the proper
judicial philosophy and there were many
many good people there but then they
were looking for something more which is
the courage of their convictions this
came from that issue of previous
Republican presidents disappointing the
voter so they wanted to see it's not
just if you have the right philosophy
but are you willing to stick to your gun
when the going gets tough when pressure
comes against you and we saw how that
ended up being an important thing in
terms of pre setup by the way you also
draw out remind us of the whole
discussion really before before this
really sets up an important aspect of it
having with the filibuster carry one
sheet oh yeah I mean we tell we wanted
to make sure people understood the
backstory of how we came here so we tell
this story this happened during a
gorgeous term when we Gorsuch as
confirmation process when the filibuster
was eliminated for of course the
filibuster was available to block judges
for century and had never really been
used against judges until the 2000s and
we talked about how the Democrats
discovered this would be a great tool as
a minority party to block judges it got
to be so bad that that it was being used
to really hamstring the president in
putting nominees in the court and when
they came to Gore such as confirmation
it was clear that he had the votes to
get confirmed but the problem was this
filibuster could allow the Democrats to
force them to have 60 votes just to get
to the final vote you only need 51 votes
to be confirmed if you need 60 votes
that means that the minority can still
be someone if you have enough people
block a nomination what happened with
Gore such was the first time there was a
partisan filibuster against a Supreme
Court nominee and that was because the
peep the extremists among the Democrats
were really pushing them saying you
don't care enough unless you actually do
everything you can to stop him which
means filibustering him this is one of
and we traced so many different ways
that that unfortunately the Democrats
were really overstepping and shot
themselves in the foot in a way they
they overstepped to do that and because
they were so extreme and people were
sand the Republicans even the moderate
Republicans and people who didn't want
to eliminate the filibuster who had had
worked hard during the Bush era not to
get rid of the filibuster people like
Susan Collins people like Lindsey Graham
John McCain they said this is ridiculous
this if they're gonna filibuster someone
like gore such someone who's so
qualified so well-respected has a great
judicial record they'll do it to anyone
and so when that filibuster was mounted
there were there were sufficient
Republicans who were just outraged with
this abuse of the procedure that they
changed those rules so that now a
filibuster can be overcome with 51 votes
which makes it effect
with the same threshold as overall
approval and that's significant because
yeah they they showed their they were
strong and firm in that moment in terms
of the Democrats but it deprived them
the ability to block the next nominee
and we pointed out with the incredible
stakes of this nomination replacing a
swing vote of Justice Kennedy and with
the incredible controversy ensued it's
hard to imagine that if the filibuster
had been left in place that that
Kavanagh would have been completely fit
so that was a TV mistake on their part
it was if they were there was one of
many strategic we learned so one thing
as fascinates me about in the book is
you develop strategies of the two sides
and the not only the high politics but
just thinking through and maneuvering
how they're going to position themselves
and whatnot develop that out for me a
little bit maybe start a maybe start
with I start with the critics first
because what struck me is again you
forget all these things they they're
kind of going through ok let's let's
perjury and then there's the racists and
card and they're all these are in things
before even gets to what we mostly
associate with it having to do with the
accusations right there's a whole series
of things right well justice Kavanagh I
used to teach a course at Harvard about
the Supreme Court and one of the things
he would tell his students is the first
48 hours after a nomination is key
that's when people get an idea about who
a nominee is and you have to really
think about how you're presenting but
both of them both sides had a 48 hours
strategy I think and so for people who
were critical of Kavanagh
they weren't even really critical of
Kavanagh so much is just critical of
whoever a Trump nominee would be so
they'd already reserved space in front
of the Supreme Court to have a protest
within moments of his name being
announced obviously that was going to be
done no matter who the nominee would be
and I think they created this um just
this idea that it was unacceptable that
any Trump nominee would be unacceptable
and then they kind of worked to figure
out what their strategy was going to be
they also knew that they didn't have
Democrats knew they didn't have the
votes so their big strategy was about
just delaying and obstructing the
nomination process however they cut the
confirmation process
so part of that was they had a really
big fight about paperwork and let me
tell you thought you were interested in
paperwork and documents you know there's
a chapter in there for you but and
actually we've been getting a kick out
of how many people did find that
interesting we're like okay good yeah
you don't worry had 1287 questions well
this is yes and his questionnaire in
response was six thousand 118 pages yeah
yes but he had a history of paperwork
that had to be dealt with so when the
Senate is considering people they're
thinking how much how we know what have
you done in your past even though he had
300 opinions you could read to
understand his judicial philosophy they
fight about his paperwork from when he
had different positions in government
including when he was a staff secretary
at the White House which meant he just
signed off on like every single piece of
paper that was in the White House for a
period of time so we're talking about
millions of documents so they fight
about that so that they can delay their
whole goal is to delay past the election
and so anything that could be done to
delay like not refusing to meet with the
nominee for a long period of time was
done and then during the hearings they
they tried their continuation of this
this is unacceptable theme by having
people get arrested and whatnot so and
the strategy for the job right and on
the other side we saw the justice and
again he knew in fact he studied we
learned all of these previous speeches
that other nominees had given to think
how do I want to present myself and I
think a lot of people knew from the
get-go and one attack that is basically
lobbied against any conservative
especially a male conservative is this
person is hates women they read me bad
for women and so those who are watching
as his acceptance speech of the
nomination saw he went through a lot of
themes in his life of women who were
influential to him his mother who was a
very early on a judge he remembers when
she went to law school as he was a child
and that was a really unique path for
women in those years of his his
commitment to hiring female law clerks
and that's something that a lot of
people in town had noted we had won one
of the a very high high flying liberal
lawyer Lisa Blatt was actually the woman
who hired me the most cases before the
Supreme Court of
woman has almost almost unanimous win
ratio she was commenting and this is one
of the reasons she supported him and and
spoke before him in front of the
Judiciary Committee saying how
impressive it is what he has done to
help promote young women's careers so he
was talking about that I think there
were a lot of people who then were also
trying to prepare him for the hearings
we learned a lot about those meetings he
was having he the Democrats were
boycotting the meetings but the
Republican senators were meeting with
him and you got a little preview each
time of some of the different questions
how thoroughly he prepared for those it
was like every one of them was a was a
final exam of his life and and he really
did that and you know the person who
prepared the most which was really
interesting of course she became
important later with Susan Collins she
had a whole additional staff she brought
on she is not a lawyer but wanted to
understand his record and did so down to
the footnotes and that was really
impressive to see the kind of detail so
for this two-hour interview they're
debating his record so but the way you
capture this is use their analogy you
study military strategy and you studied
at great length but everyone knows that
at the moment you enter the battlefield
all the strategies you out the window
mm-hmm right there's a sense of that
here once this gets going it takes on
and they're there there's there's
clearly a strategy they've clearly laid
the groundwork for things I assume a lot
of things are planned ahead and there's
that going on it but there's also just a
lot of chaos going it seems to me is
that yes and no I'd actually say one of
the things that we were probably
surprised by the most was figuring out
our learning that the White House
actually was prepared for something like
this and that was reflected from the way
they'd handled the process going well
back so even before the nominee is
picked all the shortlist errs go through
what is called colloquially a sucks
drugs and rock and roll interview and
this comes after the failed nomination
of Douglas Ginsberg he got in trouble
for smoking weed with some of the
students at Harvard and so from that
point on all potential nominees get a
pretty you know pretty critical look at
their record or anything that might come
up they actually had heard rumors from
some more liberal political activists or
judicial activists here in town that
there might be a rollout of a strategy
of some kind
they didn't have the particulars but
they weren't totally surprised so when
it comes out at the last minute people
who know their Supreme Court nomination
history or people who just were kind of
aware of politics they weren't that
surprised they could be like we didn't
know what it would be but we knew it
would be something that's one thing but
nobody realized how absolutely intense
and excruciating the next few weeks
would be and that was more because it
just seemed like up was down and reality
was turned on its head you had facts you
had things you know it seemed like
there's nothing there's nothing here to
support these allegations but the media
would present it as if there was a ton
of stuff to support it and you would
have exculpatory evidence and they would
ignore it and there was this scene where
the accuser Christine Blasi Ford names
four witnesses who can corroborate her
story all four say they're unable to
remember what she's talking about and in
the case of one is particularly
noteworthy because it's her lifelong
friend and when the friend comes out and
says you know I'm sorry I you know love
my friend but I don't know what she's
talking about
it it gets the briefest of mention on
the news and that's when the Cavanaugh's
realized oh wow this is bad like we
thought you know they hear it they're
like oh thank god
there's nothing and everybody will
acknowledge this and instead the media
just kind of downplayed it and moved on
as if it was no blip at all and that's
when they realized this is scary this is
you know you're not dealing with
rational people who are you making a
comment about modern journalism not not
the best shining moment for for the
media right would anybody in the book
you do talk about the strategy at least
on the administration's part was more
passive I think up to a point it was
aggressive but it was there was a
certain level of aggression he wanted to
be on offense but at a certain point
radically changed so these these kind of
strategies really come to end it
head-to-head with each other and the
thing kind of takes on a life of its own
it seems yeah there were some really
interesting different strategic choices
that the White House made one that we
that we were interested to learn is they
actually win in the media the focus was
almost entirely on picking a point every
aspect picking apart every aspect of
Brett Cavanaugh's life down to his
yearbook as we famously now fully recite
his all of his yearbook passages and the
meaning of variant booping
sorts of terms that none of that was
attention was paid publicly to christine
Blasi ford but we have learned from
talking with lots of people I mean DC is
a is its small town and there's a lot of
the people that grew up in that area who
still live around here and it turns out
there were a lot of stories that were
very well-known in the area and people
who are coming to the white house and
saying this the stories that we know
from from the being there at the time
that doesn't line up with the image that
we're being given of Christine Blasi
Ford they were telling stories about how
she was actually much more aggressive
with boys than the other the other girls
around her that she was in fact a very
heavy drinker so they were hearing all
of these things and in the White House
and the senator said had to make a
conscious and and strategic decision
we're not actually going to use this
even though it does go to points in her
story that that would attest to that the
credibility of what she was saying they
knew that the media would be portraying
it as attacking the victim if they did
that and then simultaneously there's a
kind of strategic tension within the
group that's that's working on behalf of
Cavanaugh because of course as Molly
mentioned he'd worked for years in the
bush White House he has lots of friends
who were part of that that community and
now he's a trump nominee and there were
so they were there's a kind of tension
between these teams of one was called
the bushes the people would say all the
brochures are saying this and they were
advising a much more calm approach kind
of demure and and saying well I I
understand and we have to we have to you
know focus on on respecting women and
that's all true but I think it has to do
with the the approach of how how one
comes out on the other team they're
going you're a trump nominee and you've
got people like like a Don Magan the
White House Counsel saying you have to
remember you are a trump nominee and
then behind the scenes they're also
preparing thinking we're gonna have to
have a hearing they'd already had roots
for the previous hearing where they
practice questions this is a very
different kind of thing it's not do you
remember
footnote 5 in this in the Supreme Court
decision how do you how do you prepare
for that so early on they had a a moot
trying to see how how is he gonna answer
some of these questions that you know
would come if they have a public hearing
that are really intrusive and and
private issues that are gonna be brought
up and probably sent
that are doing some in a very hostile
and rude way and they had they had a
mood and he in fact responded at that
mood very strongly and firmly and they
thought great he sounds perfect we don't
over rehearse this guy and then they
stopped but what in the intervening week
there was there was still these
back-and-forth of voices of how do you
approach it and so then we had even
further the America saw the Martha
McCallum interview where the approach
did seem very different and much more of
the kind of calm judicial model rather
than seeing a man who's angry at being
accused and then of course the final
very moving testimony he gave at the
Senate Judiciary Committee where you saw
what what we learned was actually in
many ways what he was feeling from the
first moment but that had been building
this whole time that emotion and
defending his his name come out for full
display so it's a turn around for a
moment let's talk about the the the
criticism as it plays out what what do
you make of all that in terms of and
there were all sorts of you know there
was a letter and it turned out who wrote
it and then the that testimony and we
have all these great figures like
Michael avenatti and how much of this
was you know coordinated and how much
you know what do you make of all that
how much of that was planned and laid
out how much of that was right so you
know this is all information that's kind
of dripping out at the time of hearings
but then we also learn more as part of
the research christine Blasi Ford was
the main accuser and I think there were
there were a number of accusers but that
her accusation was at least within the
realm of possible you know by the time
you're getting to
nationwide crime spree and serial gang
rape cartel leader and boats it off the
coast you know like those aren't I don't
think well even though some of these
things were actually mentioned by
Senators in their opening statement on
the reopening of the Tet of the of the
hearings I think most rational people
were not taking those seriously this was
at least within the realm of possibility
a letter gets sent to the house and to
it's shared with sent to the Senator
Dianne Feinstein saying that she would
like anonymity to share this share this
information
does not want her name released and what
was interesting and I mean I just found
this like fascinating to actually talk
with people who are going through the
process the Senate actually has a
procedure in place for how to handle
just this and it's something that comes
up with some frequency and the procedure
is is completely discreet it is all
handled without any public sharing of
information it does protect the names of
all people involved you have both the
accusation that can be investigated
again secret without it without it
causing any any bad problems for the
person who's accusing but you also have
a chance for the person who is being
accused to respond and so it is part of
the normal procedure it's also part of
the normal FBI vetting procedure by
circumventing that process that meant
that the anonymity couldn't be secured
but it also meant that once at the last
minute when it does get entered into the
process the White House and other people
are constrained from sharing any details
even though you have this massive public
relations campaign going on with
Washington Post stories New Yorkers
stories and whatnot and it was very
frustrating to the White House they saw
for instance conservatives not getting
it right about what this allegation was
but they couldn't even correct the
record because they were sworn to seek
your secrecy if they were to follow the
rules so anyway the letter comes out in
a way very similar to what happened and
they Anita Hill situation and then
that's what gets things going but I
think the people in the Senate who were
aware of their confirmation history were
better prepared than a lot of others and
so as they start seeing this deluge and
drip drip drip they start realizing
we're just going to get this information
out there so one of the Senate Judiciary
Committee staffers had learned a story
from Justice Thomas that I thought was
fascinating he just as Thomas said you
know how you get a dog to stop killing
your chickens the way you do it is you
take the dead chicken and you wrap it
around the neck of the dog and then the
dog loses his taste for chicken it's a
pretty visceral story so the idea with
this Senate Judiciary Committee staff
was we're going to make the fact of this
like attempt to destroy this person's
life be like that you're gonna have to
wear it around your neck if you think
it's okay to take someone who's gone
through all of these background
investigations who has a stellar
reputation whose top ranked by the
American Bar Association for his
temperament and what not who's who's
developed this with a lot of work if
you're gonna try and destroy this person
we're going to make you own it so we're
not going to play the game of taking it
you know of what the media we're doing
and they started just releasing the more
and more absurd allegations so that the
Democrats all of a sudden found
themselves on their heels as they tried
to defend what they were doing to
capital yeah and of course many of these
allegations were even in real time
coming out and saying oh I didn't
actually I sent this letter saying that
he had raped me in a cabin it really it
wasn't me I just saw this somewhere else
I thought it was really important it
should be shared or people that had
tweeted things saying they knew about
you know the rape allegation I think was
one of these four they said oh I didn't
realize that was for real I mean people
were treating it as if you can just make
statements about anyone because you're
you have a political axe to grind and
that that shouldn't have any
consequences one of the one of the
refrains that always bothered me that
week was we need the FBI to investigate
this because there's penalties for lying
to the FBI well the very same statute
applies to line to the Senate Judiciary
Committee and Senator Grassley who
himself is very protective of
whistleblowers he wants to make sure
people who are exposing wrongdoing are
treated seriously he had some very harsh
words to say the people who look I've
got a staff who I am taking to
investigate all these claims do you be a
piece of people who need to take time
away from it maybe investigating real
wrongdoing to investigate people who are
making stuff up in our admitting that
they are making stories up that's that
is a real problems abuse the process and
it's hurting true victims and so he
hated he has a long reputation for
protectiveness list of lawyers I think
that that was kind of the perfect person
to be leading the committee at that time
because he had a staff that was
dedicated to it and they were running
each of these allegations down several
of them in fact had been now referred
for criminal proceedings unfortunately
we haven't seen anything come out of
that yet I do I do would like to see
that happen though because people need
to be held accountable for the for
messing with the process like that we
don't want to see this encouraged in
future nominations is it fair to say in
your opinion that one side was fighting
in a way consistent with previous
nominations and a legal process and
another side
and a lot of the media we're fighting in
a most a post legal post constitutional
environment where it's all just politics
I think this is what was so
disheartening for so many Americans is
that they were seeing that people that
they expected to care about due process
and rule of law were just throwing it
out the window
it was something that showed itself in
different ways and what I think about as
a journalist is we have certain
standards for what we should we have
standards before we run a story about an
allegation or whatnot and these
standards were kind of being cast out
the window one reporter admitted that
she pushed a story that was sort of
laughable even the New York Times had
said it lacked credibility because she
wanted to show a pattern she knew it was
important to show a pattern well that's
not more important than getting the
facts right and I think it was very
frustrating to see that loss of AB due
process it's such an important ideal it
you know precedes our founding but it's
something that we that we all should
care a great deal about and I think
that's what people found so terrifying
actually it's not about Brett Kavanaugh
although that was horrible to see you
know his wife crying and his family and
tatters and whatnot but to see to see
what was happening to justice itself the
whole thing I've got tons of other
questions but I'm gonna open it up and
take questions we have some microphones
what am I do is I'm gonna kind of keep
an eye on it and try to keep them brief
and so when you get as many as we can in
so she'll start right here with this
fellow and where's the other mic back
there okay first of all I just want to
say that I'm a veterinarian on Capitol
Hill I can attest to the dead chicken
story seriously though I want to thank
you both for writing the book I know it
takes hours and hours of research and
time from your life from your families
so thank you very very much from writing
the book I haven't read it yet but I'm
looking forward to reading it Molly I'll
watch her every night on Fox News thank
you for being the voice of sanity and
many of the Senators who I believe
disgraced themselves during the hearings
are now candidates for the Democratic
nomination
do you believe and this may be just
speculation question that the American
public will remember the things that
they said during the hearings well one
of the ways it's important to remember
is just to have an honest media
who do probe these things it's difficult
when the media were part of the anti
Kavanagh effort to have them hold people
accountable for what they did there are
so many things I was think about you
know with Kamala Harris we write about
this in the book about how she accuses
insinuates that justice cabinet now
justice Kavanagh has perjured himself
she's asking him all these questions
it's it's an obvious perjury trap and
the media instead of saying that was
really not okay that you did that when
you didn't have evidence to support your
accusation they were writing these like
glowing stories about how awesome she
was in the hearing that day or when cory
booker is going out of his way
released committee confidential
documents and has his Spartacus moment
but um they don't they don't seem to
have a problem with it so they're not
going to ask tough questions now that
he's running for president but I do
think that we just talked about this
about how if you make false allegations
you should be held accountable it is
important for the future and if you care
about people that you hold people to
high standards and that you hold them
accountable when they do something
that's wrong and part of that is about
if you make a false allegation there
should be punishment for that there also
should be political accountability I
think for really bad reckless behavior
and so I think it's incumbent upon
voters to ultimately hold people
accountable for upholding failing to
uphold Senate decorum and processes and
again our rule of law yeah sir great
thank you very much what are your
thoughts on the American Bar
Association's
withholding it's withdrawing its
endorsement of Brett's Cavanaugh
following his testimony and then later
on just taking it all back because it
got confirmed we have yeah we have we
have the inside story but I mean this is
another really frustrating moment where
the truth was really obscured by how it
was it was portrayed to the American
people the American Bar Association has
a separate division that does its
judicial nominations now the
organization as a whole is undoubtedly
very political they take political
positions on a number of issues they try
to keep their judicial evaluations
apolitical they are not entirely
successful in doing so there been a lot
of studies showing that they
they typically just empirically rate
conservatives lower rate minorities
lower rate women women lower than other
nominees so there are a lot of reasons
to be concerned however with judge
Kavanagh they gave him their highest
rating then right as all of us is coming
out there was a letter from the
president of American Bar Association
not the head of the group that does the
evaluations that was advocating for
delay in the confirmation process it was
spun and it was really I'm sure pitched
out as a story saying the ABA is
basically walking back its universe
well-qualified well-qualified I think
there's a wonderful scene that's been in
our book talking about the fight in the
anteroom off of a hearing chamber while
Jeff Flake senator flake and Senator
Coons are trying to decide are we gonna
have this extra FBI hearing it turns out
simultaneously well there's chaos
deciding on that there's also senator
hatch who's trying to talk to the FBI
the ABA saying you need to clarify what
went on here because this is being
reported inaccurately so they actually
did clarify it of course clarification
the correction didn't really get the
same ceiling in senator Hatch's in the
bathroom he's the panty room trying to
negotiate this which just the whole
scene is that's because you already had
senator flake and senator Coons in a
single phone booth with other people
trying I mean it was it was complete
chaos there's dozens of people in here
there's literally senators almost came
to fistfights in this room so he
probably was in the the safe room over
there talking to the ABA on the phone so
it did get somewhat clarified but it
wasn't really a moment of real honor for
the ABA to take yet another political
politically motivated position on that
way in the back farthest back thank you
David James really appreciate the work
everything you've done I guess my
question is what comes next we and I'm
probably know where this is going but
have we hit bottom or we ain't seen
nothing yet we thought about that and we
actually get into this in the last
chapter as well but if this is what
happened when you were replacing a swing
vote
on the court with a nominee from a trump
nominee just imagine how much worse it
could get if you're replacing a liberal
bloc justice and there's a solid liberal
bloc that kind of votes together if
you're replacing one of those justices
with a trump nominee I fear what could
happen but that's what we're hopeful
about with getting out the facts
actually you know we saw a difference
when this all went south here at the
Kavanagh with the Kavanagh nomination
there were the people who remembered
that this had kind of been done before
whether it was with Bork or Thomas or
other nominees and there were the people
who I don't know if they were young or
didn't know their history or whatnot who
were totally taken by surprise and you
saw a difference in how they reacted to
this playbook and so I think it's
important that people know how these
things happen and know how coordinated
they are so that when which
unfortunately it's probably a when and
not an if it happens again
people aren't taken by surprise and they
know how to fight quite more effectively
wait what just fell well what did you
learn what would you say to looking
ahead to an administration or people who
might be nominated what have we learned
from this I mean because Yale for a
while there their strategy was well
let's appoint some with no paper with no
paper trail learned we learned something
from that right and then in justice
Kavanagh has probably one of the longest
and greatest records available to
everybody I mean what what what advice
do you give administration nominating
but what advice do you give we had judge
Barrett here recently well what would
you tell her or someone like that would
you know I think I think the advice you
would have given someone in a previous
administration would be keep your head
up your head down exactly and you know I
think that's bad advice
overall they would there was a great
line I think was Pam Carlin was a very
liberal lawyer and someone asked do you
think that being so out there and spoken
for your views was a good idea because
now you might not be nominated for this
prim Court and she said I don't think
standing on the sitting on the fence is
very good practice for standing up and I
think that was a good point like if you
spend your entire life keeping your
powder dry by the end by the time you
have an opportunity to do anything maybe
your powder is all gone right and so I
what was so distinguished Trump nominees
as being different is he actually
intention
we chose people who had a record and who
had a record that he knew was gonna make
some people mad and they were definitely
you know both Gorsuch and Kavanagh had
decisions where they were staking taking
bold positions that were you know maybe
they were in dissent but often more
decisions that then later the Supreme
Court advocated so he has had a bold
record already on the bench so I'm sure
she's taking that advice already and I
think it's a good recommendation the
other thing we have learned is at this
point it watch it watching the
nomination process for judges below the
Supreme Court level as well it almost
doesn't matter your record if you were
nominated by President Trump you will
get probably every Democrat voting
against you so you know might as well go
strong and don't don't be afraid to take
the decisions that you know or require
legally and that's that's the best kind
of Justice that we could hope for it was
also interesting to us we were very
pleased to be able to interview many
Supreme Court justices and one of them
said something to the effect of you know
there are people who are actually losing
their lives for this country there are
people who have real you know real
losses that they endure on behalf of the
country and if you can't handle
something like this it's you know it's
probably a good indication that you
shouldn't be nominated to the court we
were struck though by learning that
Ashleigh Cavanaugh had actually prayed
that her husband would not get the
nomination she'd gone through two brutal
confirmation battles previously and
loved her life and they had a good thing
going he had a lifetime appointment she
didn't want to go through this again but
when it came she just said this is
what's you know gonna happen and they
continue on and so I think it's a
balance you know keeping things in
perspective about what some people truly
have sacrificed but also making sure
that your family is ready to go through
what's about to come
mm-hmm
from Robert Bork to Clarence Thomas to
Brett Kavanaugh are things getting worse
is there more hyperbola or is it just
that we live in the moment and we think
it's getting worse and if it is getting
worse why I think it is clearly getting
worse I when I when I was starting to
talk about this confirmation as I was
this is my job as is trying to advocate
for
good judicial nominees so I was going
around saying getting people prepared
saying this could be you know here's
what they're gonna do they're gonna
distort his record they're going to make
smears on his character but I thought I
wanted to say rhetorically it could be
the ugliest fight we've ever seen but I
held back and I said no it's never gonna
get uglier than Justice Thomas and it
really did the things they were accusing
him of were worse and then certainly the
way it accelerated was worse the good
news is we were more prepared by having
seen those and when we go back and tell
the story of the Bork nomination and
it's it's shocking to look in retrospect
at the time not only where was the were
a lot of conservatives not really
prepared to defend the nominee from the
White House on down they were they
weren't expecting the attacks and left
they actually were intentionally not
really strongly defending him there were
people like his own son who was going on
TV sadee trying to defend his father's
record on the court and who was told to
stand down because that wasn't seemly
now unfortunately you do have to we've
realized you do have to go out when if
they're bringing the amount of firepower
and in public relations campaigns
against a nominee we have to stand up so
I do think it's getting uglier but I
think the good news is we're also
getting a little more woke to what is
happening to use the the the
colloquialism it's instead of thinking
as often many people did even after Bork
and thought a lot of Republicans kind of
thought oh good we're going back to
normal I mean Ruth Bader Ginsberg
someone who is unabashedly very liberal
works for the ACLU she got almost
unanimously confirmed and so people who
come to thought we're just gonna revert
to our to our previous method now I
think everyone realizes that's not the
case we can't just play footsie here
this is you know they're they're people
who are really working hard and so we
were more prepared going into these
battles you know what will happen next
and how many men and women will want to
step up in the face of this you know I
do think it's important since you need
to remember why this is happening though
and the why is that the Supreme Court
has gotten more political by virtue of
how it's been ruling and so as it
behaves as a political animal you start
to see more political engagement now
pull but behaving politically is
actually part of sort of a liberal
judicial philosophy this idea that if
the people don't vote a certain way or
legislature doesn't act the way you wish
it would or it's not happening in the
right timeline for you you just force it
through with your opinions and so that
is something that the Supreme Court kind
of did to itself we look a lot at how
the Senators didn't behave well or the
media didn't behave well or whatnot but
it's also the court can do a good job by
just D politicizing its rulings and so
that is something that it was kind of
comforting to see some of their rulings
where they said this year well that's
that's really a matter of politics not
for us to decide hear hear from the
bench if they could continue that it
might decrease the need for people to
behave in a political fashion but Molly
isn't there another political lesson
here as well that I mean you're looking
back it's become more politicized and
we've had this these these confirmation
battles but I mean you know a lot of
those confirmation battles were lost and
squandered because they didn't defend
themselves and as a result some justices
who got on that were appointed by
Republicans turned out to be very
different than the ones that were
originally put up who got borked I mean
how we read this we actually need a
little more politics and make the
actually minosa Preem court nominations
have always been somewhat political
right going back in it was fun to learn
the history literally going back to when
George Washington is making the first
his first appointments to the to the
court there's always gonna be a
political thing the job shouldn't be
political though the process of getting
on to a court by virtue I mean it splits
a political decision you're voting on it
how can it not be political
so yes you do need to engage in that
politically my point being it isn't the
high-stakes drama that it has become if
the court is actually just job and in
declare man that doesn't mean that you
can't so I think some that we've seen a
rhetoric about what what it means for
the court to be apolitical and I think
it's actually a lot of people maybe
targeting their comments that the Chief
Justice hoping he won't vote along with
the Conservatives saying oh if you are a
nominee of a Republican and you vote for
something that is perceived as a
conservative and that makes you
political that's not what makes you
political what makes your political is
is if the reason you vote away in a case
isn't based on what the legal result is
but based on what you think is going to
happen politically so if that's because
you're voting with your party
for political reasons or you're voting
against your party for political either
way it's a political decision if we had
judges who were actually just
interpreting the text of the laws that
would mean that they're interpreting the
laws that are passed by Democratic
congresses and signed by Democratic
presidents and in Republican congresses
and signed by Republican presidents
fairly and equally it means that some of
those results are going to be liberal
and some conservative and that's how
it's supposed to be if you're a judge
they call it calling balls and strikes
right here right front thank you
my concern is also with the future I'm
not a lawyer but my concern is with the
law schools and what's coming out of the
law schools is it really true that Yale
University shut down for a day to allow
their students to protest and I read
about the law professor University of
Pennsylvania who apparently has been
ostracized by her colleagues for
something she's written in The Wall
Street Journal so if this is what's
happening at our top law schools what's
coming out of there as far as
encouragement to be politically active
to ignore due process ignore the
presumption of innocence
if this faculty the staff of the schools
are letting their students come down to
protest right it is not a good situation
one of the things we put in the book was
about
Justice Kagan had a reputation for being
not completely hostile to conservatives
and the way that she developed that
reputation was that she literally hired
three three conservative faculty at her
law school I think we may have doubled
the number of conservative faculty at a
school that has like over 100 faculty I
mean it was it's really shocking and she
did hire like 40 some people so that
percentage made her an outlier and she
made a big production about it because
she was wanting the students to know
what conservatives what conservative you
know judicial philosophy was so that
they could argue argue it better if
that's like a good scenario if that's
something that was commendable it is a
very bad situation and it was very
disappointing to see just the way that
that Yale you know Brett Kavanaugh as an
alum is an alum of Yale and Yale Law
School and and to not care about due
process again at all of course colleges
have a general problem with do
yielded precisely the same thing for its
other alum on the court Justice Thomas
they utterly abandon him there so it's I
mean it's unfortunately not a new
phenomenon within the legal Academy but
it is a problem I think actually in some
ways it's getting better the the
creation of the Federalist Society has
it has made a bit of big support for law
students having an outlet and something
some cases on law schools that are so
for not my liberal it may be the only
exposure even the liberal students get
to someone having a conservative idea
they host lots of debates and have
people on both sides making arguments
and I think also it justices like
Justice Scalia like Justice Thomas you
know have have really been inspirational
for a new generation it was actually one
of these things we learned when they're
putting together their list of potential
nominees they're looking for people who
what they were looking for people who
developed their philosophy fairly early
and we learned that a lot of the people
had cited what happened to Justice
Thomas as the moment that made them
actually care about these things so you
might have seen there are ways in which
the Cavanaugh confirmation battle yes he
won but there ways in which the mob
attack on him worse was successful but
there also they also might have
unleashed a new awakening in some
younger students who say what I just saw
there was absolutely horrific and it
might inspire them to good things in the
future to the one thing I've seen in the
public media since your book came out I
think on Tuesday was something about how
dr. Ford scrubbed her social media
before she sent that letter is that an
important part of this book or is that
the media picking up on trivia it I mean
this came out of our interviews with
people one advantage of being local here
and having this story me know it's a big
national story but it's also a local
story Christi bazi Ford grew up in this
area her family lives here many people
she's close to still live in this area
Brett Kavanaugh grew up here Neil
Gorsuch grew up here that's apparently a
very important town but we were able to
talk to so many people who knew her
and they actually you know it's it's
it's interesting cuz it's not like it's
not like a very it's not like an extreme
thing these are people to know her they
like her they're friends with her on
Facebook and they just said yeah she had
a very political Facebook and then it
all went it all got scrubbed right
before his nomination is announced you
know some people did describe her as
having as being like crazy political
like crazy anti Trump I don't think they
meant it no like yeah yeah you know how
people are in face we don't before [ __ ]
we all have people on Facebook who are
one way or another
and she was viewed by her friends as
having as having a strong anti Trump
music that did not come out in the media
even though if we're fine you know we're
talking to so many people who are who
know this I'm pretty sure the Washington
Post has access to the same friends and
whatnot
and there was a little bit of a mention
you know they would kind of downplay it
they'd say well yes she has light
political activism but of course the one
story that wasn't scrubbed was that was
something to do with a you know those
those hats you wear to the marches which
I won't say the word for you and she was
if she was somehow mentioned in the
story about that so actual resistance
type stuff well what was it speaking of
all these little the Trivium these
little things that when reading through
the book I had forgot about that oh yeah
I first encountered in doing all these
interviews and things one of the things
that I thought was really just an
interesting if someone who was involved
in kind of counting votes the whole time
is one of the people who so there was
there a few senators that we were always
you know kind of not sure what they
would do at least some were housekeepers
and kahlan's maybe eventually obviously
Jeff Flake and it was really interesting
to learn kind of the backstory of how
some of them had approached it in
particular for me too to learn more
about Susan Collins's involvement in
this I mentioned out how involved she
was early on in terms of her preparation
I think if I had known how how she
approached these nominations I wouldn't
have been as worried in the moment we
learned things like that as soon as she
saw the letter from that had been sent
to senator Feinstein that actually it
raised not not concerns from her
obviously like let's look into this but
there was a big red flag on and that was
the date at the top of the letter that
it was sent in July and that this is
September now that she's seeing it and
how why is this not going through the
process and as a senator she knows this
is the correct process and seeing how
she even we we have another a really
interesting story realizing that there
was actually a conservative Republican
senator who halfway through the the
second hearing so when when it's kind of
the darkest moment it looks like 414
Kavanagh heads had proposed her maybe
now is the time we go to the president
and suggest that he trade Kevin out for
a new nominee and that she actually said
no I think we need to hear both sides
the story before we make any decisions
like that and so the very person the
person we were worried about more
actually was a counseling respect for
the presumption of innocence in the rule
of law and someone who we probably would
have thought oh this guy's you know
certainly on our team this one but you
know you know you never know behind the
scenes you know that I learned and I
like learning about the human aspect of
the story when I was covering it I was
just thinking these big picture issues
and you know the actual nomination but
learning about how actual people were
affected you know close to home I
mentioned about Ashleigh Cavanaugh
praying that he wouldn't get the
nomination
but even right before he gets the
nomination we learn about how he Justice
cabinet is a lector at his church so
he's reading and he's just wearing like
a coat it is a Sunday he's wearing a
coat he's working in his chambers
preparing for the possibility of a
nomination and he gets a call to come to
the White House and he doesn't feel like
he's dressed appropriately so he manages
this surreptitious you know channeling
of a suit getting into his car he
actually has he has protection at that
point from from federal marshals so a
suit gets delivered into his car his
wife is rolling it up and putting it
through the window and then he's
changing in the backseat then he has to
change into another car so that nobody's
following him and just learning details
like that was just like oh you forget
these are like real people who are
having like these crazy things going on
on a personal level - yeah way back to
get right back there yeah
I think a lot of people on the Ray are
gonna want retribution it's not
necessarily a good thing so if we lose
the house outside the Senate and the
White House what would you say to
Republicans who want to play hardball
and maybe use some of these same tactics
which were we're so upset about how how
would you carve a path forward or
avoiding you know I have been working on
judicial nominations since 2010 that
means they've been during the Obama
years when we supposed to boasted
nominate judges nominee during the Trump
years and one thing that I'm very proud
of is that for you know working on
justice Kagan's nomination for example
we're very much believed and now not all
you know not everyone shares this view
there's some senators who think you kind
of if someone's qualified you need to
vote for them I think no you need to we
do need to make sure that someone who
has a very clear judicial philosophy
that it's someone who has a record of
that they'll support the Constitution is
written in the law I think we should
have a vigorous debate about their
judicial record but I also think that
there shouldn't be any quarter given to
the kind of smear campaigns and
underhanded tactics that were used in
the Cavanaugh nomination I'm very proud
that through justice Kagan's nomination
through the nomination of Merrick
garland which I also was working during
that none of that ever happened and we
actually have a story injustice on trial
about how garland was concerned when he
was first nominated that that might I'm
worried people are going to maybe attack
me personally and a friend of his who
was conservative said I I know these
people who are working on this and
that's not gonna happen
and that he was relieved to see that it
didn't so I hope that people on our side
will maintain that approach I think we
need to have a fervent battle of ideas
but not let it descend into the politics
of personal destruction
I haven't read your book but I noticed
in the index he had a few references to
Planned Parenthood and I'm wondering
what Planned Parenthood what what they
had to do with the nomination I presume
they would oppose and what special
interest groups what do they do to paint
a pickle nominee is either a villain or
a saint whatever their particular
interest happens to be right and special
interest groups playing a role in
nominations is something that does have
a long history we particularly think of
what happened with the Bork nomination
where they very effectively came
together to scuttle that one this was no
different and so I mentioned that there
was that protest moments after Kavanagh
was nominated that was a protest that
had a coalition of several dozen groups
several dozen progressive groups
including abortion groups who who felt
that this was important of course it is
important because of how our Supreme
Court jurisprudence has sort of made
this an issue for the court and they
began their activism even prior to this
to the naming of Kavanagh one of the
things that we were struck by with Susan
Collins is she becomes this big player
she was actually targeted in June with
hangers as sort of a veiled threat about
her vote and abortion and whatnot so
this is something that people were very
active we learned about how and this is
actually public information this wasn't
we did a lot of really good reporting
but this was just something we were kind
of surprised that they were being open
about they paid for protestors to come
in from across the country they gave
them training on how to get arrested and
how to disrupt hearings and they they
paid their bail money and whatnot and
some of these groups were of course you
know abortion abortion groups that that
that made this an issue and that showed
in their activism yeah you could
apologize I got to press you for a
moment before you kind of you punted the
first time around but there's a serious
journalism question that occurred in
these hearings about how things were
reported I mean when you what do you
make of all that now and you look back
and see we actually know what happened
we know what a lot that you're doing a
lot of more of the facts and you go back
and I assume in researching you look you
go back you reread what the actual press
actually was reporting or not reporting
what do what do you this is part of why
we wrote the book actually we learned
that there
people who were actually part of the
anti Kavanagh effort as journalists who
said well now I'm gonna I'm gonna turn
into you know I'm just I'm gonna write a
straight straight book on this we
thought this is this is certainly not
how it's going to happen and people who
were involved in the process we're happy
to tell their story they just don't want
to tell their story to people who had
been so involved in the antique cabinet
effort it's hard to trust someone that
they will take your story seriously that
way at the same time we just wanted to
tell the story as accurately as possible
while we were going through it though
there were some pretty horrifying things
that we saw you know just learning
different things about facts that were
obscured or its storylines that weren't
picked up you know that's one thing that
comes to mind is NBC News actually knew
prior to the confirmation vote that
Michael a vanadis supposed second
witness to the serial gang rape cartel
thing was disputing how he characterized
what what she would say they knew that
and they sat on that until after the but
weeks after the vote I mean there's just
no journalistic defense for that and
it's you know they lost so much
credibility this way and it doesn't need
to be this but you don't need you know
we have our views and whatnot but you
don't need to do that you can you can
just the story itself is so interesting
and we owe it to all people to report
you know as fairly as we can
way in the back as Cavanaugh has made
his first couple decisions in this term
I feel like there's been a couple of
been even applauded by the left and none
that have really been like really
denounced that he's making some like
really conservative choices how do you
think those will play in the elections
for like Senator Collins and some of
these other sender's since he hasn't
been an ultra conservative judge for the
bench well I think justice Cavanaugh on
the Supreme Court has actually been the
same kind of judge she was in his 12
years in the DC Circuit so yet his his
decisions have been the same kind of
thoughtful well-written kind of balanced
pieces of work that we've seen before
yes he is he is he joined really
a for justice sometimes five justice a
liberal or conservative block that now
is on the court you've seen every member
of the conservative justices join the
Liberals at one point or other this term
justice you know including Thomas I mean
so if we look just as Thomas is doing in
every was right but but so so I think
sometimes we we try to draw these lines
in ways that don't actually line up with
some of the legal questions are really
just technical legal questions that are
hard to parse out but some of the some
of the themes that were there from his
time in the at the appeals court and
continued in our several really strong
decisions on religious freedom for
example he had a great concurrence in
the in the case about the the Maryland
cross as well as decisions there are a
few decisions and they can they get into
kind of the weeds and in many cases of
administrative law and things but very
important cases this term pushing back
on abuses of the separation of powers
trying to make sure that the the
legislature has its role as making in
for making laws and then it doesn't get
seeded to it an overgrown administrative
state and that was very important to
move the court and then Molly alluded to
the gerrymandering decision where the
court the courts have been asked to more
or less take a political role and almost
pick political winners and losers say
when something is or isn't political
enough gerrymandering that's a very
dangerous task to ask courts to do when
there is no legal standard to apply and
he was it was absolutely part of that
majority in that case so there have been
I think on average what you've seen is
this him carrying on in the same pattern
that you have for twelve years in the
court that's why you want some with a
long record because then you know
exactly how they'll be when they when
they're on the court and he's continued
to be a very principled justice but also
income and to check-check people when
they make apocalyptic predictions I mean
they ran a similar similar he'll be
awful for women game plan against Souter
as they did cabinet right anyone would
say he voted in Planned Parenthood first
Casey to uphold Roe vs. Wade so they
they said he's going to be end of
abortion and turns out and we were told
that justice Cavanaugh had temperament
issues that would make him unsuitable
well we've got a full term I think it's
worth looking back and saying who was
telling the truth about these
predictions and who was and his
colleagues obviously he's also praised
his collegiality and his temperament so
this was just really detached but we did
learn that a colleague thinks that the
main difference that they've the main
difference they've observed this was a
liberal Justice said that Kennedy was
more inclined to do Shakespeare
references in Cavanaugh is more inclined
to do sports references you get a very
good judicial answer but what about how
do you think this Namit going through
this nomination would affect him
personally I mean Molly talked about the
personal stories I mean this has had to
have it I mean what kind of effects that
have either either it's gonna make him
that much you know stronger or does he
want to know how does one you know as I
affect him as a judge going forward well
I think again when you've got someone
who's been doing this job day in and day
out for 12 years I would think he
doesn't want to have it change him it's
more of a matter of how can I maintain
this record of principle that you know
you don't want to turn into a
reactionary in one way or the other
because of a horrible process he went
through but we certainly have heard from
a lot of people how much it strengthened
their marriage their family I think it
you know you you have to grow as a
person going through a situation like
that that tries you in every possible
level yeah I'd say I think some people
would like him to be to have the
experience make him more susceptible to
you know leftists and other people would
hope it would steal him even more as a
conservative judge but a wise person had
said to us early on for better for worse
it's not going to change him he's had
that 12 years on the court he has grown
up in DC he already has experienced some
of these things he will continue to be
exactly how he was yeah well as I said
before I think this is just a wonderful
book you've done a wonderful not only
capturing all those facts in that
narrative but the way you put together
is quite good give any final thoughts or
things we've not talked about that you'd
like to so many there's a lot in there
so it's kind of it's it's it's fun and
it was I mean it was that yeah that was
a fun thing you're you're doing all that
again these high-level discussions about
judicial philosophy and whatnot but
you're also just learning what it was
like as people right through the
hearings a lot of men
who we interviewed said you cannot you
know you can't don't put this on the
record but I'm gonna admit I cried
during Cavanaugh's testimony I mean
we're all new you all were all of
knowingly okay tears um but learning
that Melania Trump had told her husband
midway through you know that woman is
lying don't you we thought that was
interesting because it's also just like
what's happening in everybody's living
room and and there were people millions
of people's having this conversation but
it wasn't what you were hearing in
newsrooms who for some remember we had a
quote from one journalist saying like
the holes in her story actually make her
more credible and it was like I don't
think that's yeah I think if there's one
other person we didn't get a chance to
do well they're actually so there's so
many there's so many stories of courage
in this and it's just a couple more that
come to mind we didn't get a chance to
talk to Rachel Mitchell it's the woman
who was who is interviewing her at the
if this Judiciary Committee hearing in
the moment I think a lot of people
didn't really give her a lot of credit
people were hoping maybe she'd be a
bulldog and jump down her throat and do
some dramatic moments and Harry Mason oh
yeah Perry Mason moment and she'd walk
out say no that's it I mean oh you know
that's not what her job is
her job is actually she's a sex crimes
prostitute but she specializes in
interviewing victims getting the
information and the facts so she knows
if there's a case to be brought and
after she went through this and of
course uncovered a lot of really
inconsistencies in the story she
presented those facts to the the
Republican senators and said there's not
only not enough facts here to convict
there's not enough facts here for a
search warrant this is a Syria this case
has is not well substantiated and she
actually got a standing ovation from
those those senators and we learned that
it was something that was very important
to people who were there's boats that
were in play and then the other person I
think that it you know is a great person
we haven't touched on of courage is
Leland Keyser that was in Molly alluded
to her a friend of Christine Blasi
Ford's a Liberal Democrat all her life
who simply said I I remember that summer
very well but that's I don't remember
anything like the story you're telling
me and even later I think you know began
to have issues with people pressuring
her to change her story that's a very
difficult position we put in when you're
trying to be supportive of a friend but
also be faithful to the truth and she
was incredibly courageous to take the
stage
that she did in favor of the truth we we
are actually kind of being careful about
this we did talk to a ton of people and
we're just kind of the vast majority
asked that it be on background and so
we're just kind of and there were some
people don't forget for various reasons
but we actually had we were so thrilled
with the amount of access that we had to
people at all levels that's good so the
book again is justice on trial the
Cavanaugh confirmation the future the
Supreme Court by Molly Himalayan Kerry
said we're gonna thank you very much
thank you all for joining us as one
[Applause]